[Musik]
klimaschutz wird gesetzt die große
koalition bringt erste teile des
klimapakets durch den bundestag
brisante vorwürfe im fall amri wurden
ermittlungen vor dem terror anschlag am
berliner weihnachtsmarkt abgewürgt und
das ende der ära hoeneß nach 40 jahren
70 mester fc bayern aus der ersten reihe
zurück
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und ein
herzliches willkommen zu den heute
-nachrichten die vom sport hat nachher
norbert jemand ein stück von mir trotz
aller kritik haben die abgeordneten von
union und spd im bundestag heute etliche
gesetze zum klimaschutz verabschiedet
sie sollen sicherstellen dass
deutschland die klimaziele für 2030
erreicht
für verbraucher ändert sich folgendes
wer co2 verursacht zahlt auch dafür ab
2021 entsprechend werden dann heizen und
tanken teurer
erst mal nur um rund drei cent pro liter
dann jedes jahr etwas mehr
schon ab april steigen die preise fürs
fliegen um fünf bis zehn euro pro
strecke gefahren
dagegen wird billiger wohl um rund zehn
prozent weil ab januar die
mehrwertsteuer auf die tickets sinkt und
auch die pendler werden entlastet bei
der pendlerpauschale
aber nur wenn ihr weg zur arbeit länger
als 21 kilometer ist reicht das alles
viele sagen nein entsprechend lebhaft
wurde im bundestag diskutiert weniger es
wird von allen seiten geburt gefrotzelt
von einigen auch gebrüllt es geht
emotionaler zu im plenum als üblich und
es liegen welten zwischen regierung und
opposition in der bewertung des
klimapakets das gefährdet unsere
wirtschaft energieversorgung sowie
mobilität und damit den wohlstand
unseres landes und unserer bürger
wir beschließen heute ein gutes paket es
war in der gesamtheit sehen muss dass er
das thema klimaschutz voranbringen
das aber in der lage ist dieses land
nicht zu überfordern sie sind an der
menschheitsaufgabe klimaschutz
gescheitert mit den maßnahmen werden
sich
es selbst gesetzten klimaziele nicht
erreichen
im gesetz steckt ein neuer mechanismus
wenn zb die ministerin für
landwirtschaft oder der minister für
verkehr zukünftig ihre co2 vorgaben
reisen müssen sie in ihren ressorts
sofort nach steuern das hohe haus sagt
dieser regierung welche
einsparpotenziale die jährlich in jedem
ressort für erreichen hat damit machen
wir klimaschutz gesetzlich verbindlich
die opposition wirft er noch rote karten
in die urne stimmt gegen das gesetz der
co2 preis sei zu niedrig die maßnahmen
insgesamt zu wenig effektiv und die
kosten für den bürger zu hoch wir
brauchen eine bundesregierung die eine
vorstellung davon hat wie wir
solidarisch unsere gesellschaft
gestalten können wir klima gerechtigkeit
erreichen können das alles haben sie
nicht sie haben fertig die regierung
aber will weitere gesetze verabschieden
zum kohleausstieg und zur windkraft über
die streiten peter altmaier und svenja
schulze aber noch und dann haben
bundesrat und möglicherweise auch
gerichte noch ein wörtchen mitzureden
ein langer weg zum klimaschutz ja noch
die einschätzung unseres umweltexperten
volker anders
guten abend reicht es jetzt um die
klimaziele 2030 zu erreichen also das
gesetz das maßnahmenpaket so wie es
jetzt auf dem tisch liegt reicht unter
gar keinen umständen punkt so muss man
es erst mal sagen aber es gibt ja diesen
dynamischen faktor die klima anstrengen
sollen ja nachgeschärft werden immer
dann wenn absehbar ist dass ein sektor
das ziel offenbar nicht erreicht dann
muss es eben neue maßnahmen geben das
ist sozusagen die theorie ist ganz
wichtig dass die kernaussage in diesem
gesetz aber die frage ist wie wird das
dann umgesetzt wer kümmert sich dann
tatsächlich darum und wir reden über 20
30 bis dahin werden wir noch ein paar
bundesregierungen haben
keiner kann wirklich abschätzen ob das
so wirklich nachgeschärft werden wird
wie es werden muss das ist das große
fragezeichen und nur wenn da eine
garantie bestünde dann könnte man sagen
ja es gibt eine chance
wie sieht es im europäischen vergleich
ist deutschland jetzt vorreiter
nein überhaupt nicht es gibt mindestens
neun europäische länder die schon längst
ein klimaschutz gesetzt haben die ersten
das waren die schweiz
schon im jahr 2000 england 2008
österreich 2011 alle diese gesetze sind
sehr unterschiedlich aufgebaut die
österreicher zum beispiel haben sofort
gesagt wir gucken die sektoren an und
machen so co2 deckel drauf und sagen
okay bis zu diesem jahr so viel co2 zb
im verkehrssektor so viel im
gebäudesektor das kommt bei uns auch
aber erst ab 20 26 bis dahin hofft man
halt über die bepreisung das
hinzukriegen also wir sind auf gar
keinen fall vorreiter na ja vielleicht
haben wir jetzt sozusagen den anschluss
hingekriegt denn immerhin und das haben
alle klimaschutzgesetze gemeinsam im
kern gibt es jetzt einen planungsprozess
einen gesetzlich hinterlegten
planungsprozess wieder die frage der ist
nur so gut wie die umsetzung die dann
folgt man für diese wichtigen
informationen volker anders
welche neuerungen da beim heizen fliegen
und pendeln auf uns alle zukommen haben
wir online in einem überblick
zusammengestellt auf heute de finden sie
noch mal viele daten und fakten zum
nachlesen
für mehr klimaschutz bräuchte es vor
allem auch mehr klimafreundlichen strom
aus windkraft zum beispiel ein problem
dabei die geplanten abstandsregeln die
sind heftig umstritten
die bundesregierung will mindestens
einen abstand kilometer abstand zwischen
einen kilometer abstand zwischen windrad
und wohnhaus dagegen haben sich jetzt
auch die umweltminister der länder
ausgesprochen
der mindestabstand sei das falsche
signal so werde der ausbau der windkraft
verhindert umwelt- und klimaschutz das
kernthema der grünen sie sind
erfolgreich wie nie in umfragen stabil
zweitstärkste partei hinter der union
sie haben mit annalena baerbock und
robert habeck ein populäres führungsduo
und jetzt wollen sie endlich auch wieder
mitregieren das hat robert habeck zum
auftakt des bundesparteitags klar
gemacht aus bielefeld berichtet patricia
wieder meyer es ist genau 20 jahre her
dass die grünen schon einmal in
bielefeld getagt haben damals eskalierte
der streit um den kosovo einsatz der
nato und damit der bundeswehr in der
farbbeutel attacke auf joschka fischer
heute sind bilder wie diese undenkbar
die partei ist wesentlich geeinter und
harmonischer ganz selbstbewusst steht
sie sich für eine erneute
regierungsbeteiligung im bund auf das
macht auch der parteivorsitzende habeck
in seiner eröffnungsrede
wo ist dieser geist geblieben die großen
dinge in deutschland zu denken da setzen
wir ein mit diesem parteitag gebrauchen
wieder mut und leidenschaft die großen
dinge nach vorne zu bewegen
eine wehrhafte demokratie fordert er und
eilt heftig aus gegen die afd
wenn die afg nach der thüringer war ein
abend lang sagt ihr wahlerfolg war der
sieg über hass und hetze
dann haben wir eine art welche sprach
verdrehung in deutschland dann dort
wahrheit lüge und wahrheit und da müssen
wir widersprechen dass ökologie und
ökonomie sich nicht ausschließen dass
klimaschutz neue arbeitsplätze schafft
darum soll es gehen hier in bielefeld
stecken gerade in einer konjunkturellen
flaute und aus unserer sicht ist es
nicht nur eine flaute sondern eine
strukturelle krise und die können wir
nur angehen werden wir die art des
wirtschaftens fit machen für das
einundzwanzigste jahrhundert digital
aber auch im sinne einer klimaneutralen
wirtschaftsweise meinem markenkern beim
thema klimaschutz könnte es jedoch
streit mit der basis geben vor allem die
jugend fordert radikalere maßnahmen die
einen höheren co2 preis des abends denn
das 180 euro pro tonne co2
es wurde alles gesorgt handeln morgen
stehen die wahlen des bundesvorstands an
das habe ich und wer bock wiedergewählt
werden gilt als sicher
neue schwere vorwürfe im fall eines amri
dem attentäter vom berliner
breitscheidplatz verheerende pannen sind
schon lange bekannt jetzt aber sagt ein
leitender beamter
das bka und wohl auch der damalige
bundesinnenminister hätten ermittlungen
gegen den terroristen abgewürgt mit
einem lastwagen war alles amri am 19
dezember 2016 über den weihnachtsmarkt
gerast der anhänger der terror miliz es
tötete zwölf menschen david geppert
berichtet
derzeit wird wieder der weihnachtsmarkt
aufgebaut an berliner breitscheidplatz
wo anis amri zwölf menschen tötete eine
tat die noch immer fragen aufwirft
hier steht die frage im raum ob die
spitze des bundeskriminalamts oder ob
auch die spitze des
bundesinnenministeriums einfluss
genommen hat auf die überwachung von
annes amri durch eine person zehn monate
vor dem anschlag auf dem
breitscheidplatz sollte sich dieser
befund bestätigen dann müsste die
geschichte rund um diesen anschlag
vermutlich neu geschrieben werden
ein zeuge kriminalhauptkommissar aus nrw
berichtete gestern im u-ausschuss bundes
innenministerium und bka sollen hinweise
eines informanten auf die gefährlichkeit
am ries als lästig empfunden haben und
dass ein vertreter einer bundesbehörde
ihm gegenüber mitgeteilt hat das wohl
der damalige bundesinnenminister de
maizière und die hausleitung des bka
darauf hingewirkt haben dass diese
quelle kalt gestellt wird dass diese
quelle mundtot gemacht wird diese quelle
ein langjähriger v-mann informant aus
nrw das bundesinnenministerium weist
heute auch im namen des bka alle
vorwürfe zurück und stellt die
glaubwürdigkeit des lka beamten in frage
die aussage wurde weder wörtlich noch
sinngemäß durch den beamten des bka
getätigt bereits ein inhaltliches vier
augen gespräch hat es nicht gegeben es
fehlen die hand atmos fehlen die
aussagen der weiteren beteiligten wenn
diese aussagen im untersuchungsausschuss
getroffen worden sind erst dann können
wir eine abschließende beurteilung
vornehmen
auch thomas de maizière der ehemalige
innenminister solle laut opposition nun
zeitnah im ausschuss befragt werden
es gibt möglicherweise hoffnung für die
kriegsgeplagten menschen in der ost
ukraine
frankreichs präsident marko spricht von
bedeutenden fortschritten bei den
friedensbemühungen und hat russlands
präsident putin und dessen ukrainischen
kollegen selensky nach paris eingeladen
auch bundeskanzlerin merkel wird an dem
gipfel am 9
dezember teilnehmen
us-präsident schon zieht im streit um
seine steuererklärungen jetzt sogar vors
oberste gericht denn zuletzt hatte ein
bundesgericht entschieden dass new
yorker staatsanwälte die herausgabe der
dokumente verlangen können es geht um
mutmaßliche schweigegeld zahlungen an
zwei frauen
die anwälte des präsidenten wollen das
mit allen mitteln verhindern sie
argumentieren solche ermittlungen gegen
einen amtierenden präsidenten verbietet
die verfassung auch politisch gegenwind
für den präsidenten das parlament
untersucht weiter die ukraine affäre
also ob donald trump eigene interessen
über das wohl des landes gestellt hat
heute sagt eine wichtige zeugen aus die
frühere us botschafterin in der ukraine
partie wissen berichtet sie verspricht
die wahrheit zu sagen wie alle zeugen
hier marie jovanovic us botschafterin in
der ukraine bis donald trump sie im mai
2009 10 vorzeitig ab rief sie sei
offenbar ein hindernis gewesen für die
neben außenpolitik von trumps
persönlichem anwalt rudy giuliani mit
grundlosen unterstellungen sorgten sie
dafür dass der präsident seine
botschafterin absetzt obwohl das
außenministerium wusste dass die
anschuldigungen falsch waren und die
quellen obskur das sollte jeden in
diesem raum beunruhigen botschafter sind
das symbol der vereinigten staaten im
ausland mitten hinein in die anhörung
platzt eine meldung donald trump
beschimpft mario banovic per twitter
noch während sie aus sagt wo immer sie
hinging sei es schlecht ausgegangen
die zeugin ringt um worte ich weiß nicht
was der präsident damit bezweckt aber es
wird einschüchternd botschafterin einige
von uns nehmen die einschüchterung von
zeugen sehr sehr ernst so ernst dass die
demokraten dies zu einem eigenen
anklagepunkt gegen donald trump machen
wollen schon gestern sprachen sie den
hauptvorwurf offen ausbleibe rhi
bestechung nach der verfassung ein grund
für amtsenthebung
zugibt und perfekt nennt war genau das
gegenteil bestechung in washington
verfolgen menschen das kongress hearing
live im fernsehen nichts schockierendes
oder revolutionäres meint er
sie war sehr entlarven dass sie sich von
trump eingeschüchtert fühlt sich trotz
anhörungen liegt die zustimmungsrate für
den präsidenten noch bei 50 prozent vor
der aussage von marijo banovic
es ist vollbracht nach einer marathon
sitzung über 15 stunden haben die
haushaltsexperten des bundestags den
etat fürs nächste jahr festgezurrt der
haushalt wächst um 5,5 milliarden euro
mehr geld gibt es für klimaschutz die
bundeswehr und die familien trotz
wirtschaftsflaute will die regierung das
ohne neue schulden schaffen
nach einem raser unfall mit zwei toten
muss der 21-jährige fahrer für fünf
jahre ins gefängnis
das landgericht stuttgart verurteilte
ihn wegen einem verbotenen kraftfahrzeug
rennen mit todesfolge ursprünglich war
der mann wegen mordes angeklagt er war
im märz in einem gemieteten sportwagen
mit 165 stundenkilometern durch
stuttgart gereist und hatte die
kontrolle verloren
integration wird einfacher wenn
muslimische gemeinden in deutschland
möglichst viele kontakte in die
nachbarschaft ins lokale leben haben ein
förderprogramm soll jetzt moschee
gemeinden helfen die sich stärker öffnen
wollen
geld gibt es für
nachbarschaftsinitiativen
öffentlichkeitsarbeit und ähnliche
projekte alexander rettig über den start
der aktion
sie wollen fester teil des städtischen
lebens seien die gläubigen der ditib
moschee gemeinde im rheinischen monheim
ein kurzer draht zur kommune und ein
offener umgang mit nachbarn und kirchen
gehört für sie dazu
wir wollen uns in monheim engagieren wir
wollen den nachbarn und in monheim
anzeigen dass wir das wir
freundschaftliche beziehungen haben
wollen und das ist uns in den letzten
jahren eigentlich ganz gut gelungen ein
kurs der öffnung und transparenz genau
den soll das förderprogramm moscheen für
integration unterstützen
es umfasst sieben millionen euro für
drei jahre gefördert werden sozialarbeit
beratungsangebote oder integrationskurse
von 50 moscheen können teilnehmen die
auswahl erfolgt durch unabhängige träger
das ziel dass wir das muslimische leben
in deutschland ja auch nutzen um den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt in
unserem lande zu verstärken
das tut nicht jede ditib moschee im
september 2018 lud die kölner
zentralmoschee den türkischen
präsidenten erdogan zu einem
umstrittenen besuch ein
ein auftritt der zeige wie sehr der
größte moschee verband von ankara
gesteuert werde sagen kritiker teilweise
sind die moscheen in den letzten
jahrzehnten verantwortlich gewesen für
die entwicklung von
parallelgesellschaften solange sie das
auch weiter tun sind sie bei so einer
aufgabe kein partner der monheimer ditib
ableger möglicherweise schon der baut
gerade ein neues gemeindezentrum mit
hilfe der stadt weil die ihm vertraut
auch für den erfolg des
integrationsprogramms wird die auswahl
der moscheegemeinden entscheidend sein
es ist nicht alles gold was glänzt das
hätten die angestellten der sparkasse
göttingen beherzigen sollen
denn zehn mal drehte ihnen ein
18-jähriger unechte goldbarren an und
kassierte dafür insgesamt 300.000 euro
der junge mann hatte die vergoldeten
fälschungen auf ebay ersteigert das
jugendschöffengericht göttingen
verurteilte ihn zu zwei jahren auf
bewährung
ihre geschichten aber gold für
deutschland gab es auch bei der parallel
in derlei geräten in dubai genau am
schlusstag der weltmeisterschaft
sprinter johannes floors mit weltrekord
zum doppelweltmeister von dubai der
sprinter siegte auch über 400 meter und
sein teamkollege leon schäfer der holte
silber über 100 meter
leon schärfer verfolgt gleich nach
seinem finale auf das 400 meter rennen
von teamkollege johannes flores der
beidseitig unterschenkelamputierte 24
jährige läuft ein einsames rennen gegen
die uhr
dass er in neuer weltrekordzeit von 45
78 sekunden souverän gewinnt erst als
ich über die ziellinie bin und dann noch
eine fünf wochen kamera gestanden ist
was sich irgendwie auch ein gesagt habe
ich will diese 5 das war ein
gigantisches gefühl auch der
oberschenkel amputierte leon scheffer
hat kurz zuvor sein zweites wm gold vor
augen wird aber noch vor der ziellinie
vom senden wagner abgefangen
ich bin zufrieden war eine sehr gute wm
waren super stimmung hier
ich bin an sich habe an sich hat wie
kann das ganze deutsche team sein mit
noch einmal silber und gold am
schlusstag ja morgen abend deutschland
gegen weissrussland teamchef löw hat
einen sieg versprochen und sich heute
für die beiden letzten em quali spiele
bei den torhütern manuel neuer und marc
andré ter stegen festgelegt manu spielt
morgen gegen weißrussland in gladbach
und gegen nordirland in frankfurt
spielen das ende einer ära uli hoeneß
tritt heute abend in münchen auf der
hauptversammlung des fc bayern als
präsident ab und verabschiedet sich aus
der ersten reihe ein emotionales
urgestein so kennt man mister fc bayern
münchen uli hoeneß ist halt doch nicht
sein dass wir hier kritisiert werden
dafür dass wir uns seit vielen jahren
den arsch aufreißen und dann kannst du
dir deine dinge hinter die ohren spiel
bringen polarisiert hat er immer als
visionär und machtmensch mit großem herz
für den fußball
er hat natürlich im deutschen fussball
schon zog geprägt wie kaum ein anderer
als spieler europa und weltmeister mit
27 durch knieverletzung gezwungen die
seiten zu wechseln management statt
muskelaufbau mit sieben millionen mark
schulden übernimmt er den verein führt
ihn in vier jahrzehnten zum top klub
sportlich und finanziell immer mit dem
credo die kunst ist nicht nach oben zu
kommen sondern oben zu bleiben
seinen tiefpunkt anklage und
verurteilung wegen steuerhinterziehung
nach der haft rückkehr als präsident des
fc bayern münchen nun abschied mit 67
servus und servus sondern besitzt auch
ja gleich aber jetzt noch das wetter das
wird zum wochenende wieder nasse die
details hat gleich aus dem verlies
marietta slomka begrüßt sie um 10 im
heute-journal und hier ist morgen petra
gerster dran
danke für ihr interesse machen sie sich
ein schönes wochenende und auf
wiedersehen als schon gut und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter
diese kleine tief über der alpenregion
das hat eine ungewöhnliche zypern und
zieht von süd nach nord und wird dann am
abend den norden deutschlands erreichen
dann gibt es ja noch einen blauen klecks
das hier wird zu einem sturmtief
heranwachsen und weiteren regen und
schnee von süden an die alpen drücken
wir schauen mal in die nacht da gibt es
viele wolken mit dem tief dass
allmählich nach norden zieht und diesen
regen hier auslöst ansonsten gibt es
einen stramm südostwind an der ostsee
und da kommt eben auch mildere luft an
oder neiße gibt es sieben bis acht grad
ganz im westen in der eifel minus drei
grad morgen lockt hat es im süden
allmählich auf und es wird einfach
ruhiger nach norden aber eher nicht da
sind viele wolken unterwegs ist
unterwegs es regnet und der wind ist
rechtskräftig sind an den dicken fallen
temperaturen erreichen dabei im osten 12
grad an den alpen 4 grad
schauen wir auf die nächsten tage am
sonntag geht's noch wechselhaft weiter
höchste temperaturen bis 14 grad sogar
im osten deutschlands aber dann wird es
in der kommenden woche schon wieder
etwas ruhiger aber auch kühler damit ein
schöner abend